now are you ready for NATO the mo this
propaganda from NATO
okay I'm gonna go through this it's a
thread it's ten tweets where we have to
go through all of them okay put it to
you this way America's giving the most
money out of any country so I figured
that since it's our money we we we want
to know where it's going so of course
okay so this is NATO this the official
NATO account this is like a NATO parody
just so you know ready
I've always been a journalist one day
two of Russia's full-scale Invasion I
went and joined the Armed Forces of
Ukraine this is Pavlov's story this is
this is him
uh a true People's Army it contained
ordinary workers and company directors
parents and their children and school
teachers theater people the new
University graduates yeah that's what
happens when you're conscripting people
by force like that you mean yeah is that
balding bankrupt it could be Baldwin
bankrupt is that you
um people bring Knowledge and Skills
from their civilian uh professions into
the army as no one had gotten around to
tell them it can't be done they said
about creating new ways of solving
problems with our money
uh there's we're getting to a I'm gonna
skip ahead just a little bit here just a
little bit okay so Moscow tried to uh
divide Ukraine but achieve the opposite
okay that's not true because half of
them are here uh if the Ukraine loses in
Moscow gets its way the domino effect
might be felt around the world okay okay
okay okay okay
uh we could skip this one actually here
isn't that aren't you just making a
stronger case for why we should hang on
to our money and train our guys and be
ready for any thing that might happen to
us I want you to please read a tweet
nine out of ten from no I want you to
read
ah yeah why are you making me read this
because it's I because I've been waiting
for you to read this so um
oh it's gonna be painful okay this is
from the official NATO account Ukraine
is hosting one of the great epics of
this Century get regularly oh God I
can't
we are Harry Potter and William Wallace
the navi and Han Solo
or escaping from Shawshank and blowing
up the Death Star
we are fighting with the Harkins and
challenging Thanos
we [__] deserve to lose everything we
[__] deserve this
we deserve every [__] I take it back
you people in East Palestine you get
what you [__] deserve along with the
rest of us
did you ever think we were gonna get to
the point where there was literally a
war where one side of the war was a
bunch of soy boys and [__] like it's
[__] crazy they're fine and I'm not
talking about fighting Memoirs I'm
talking about fighting actual Wars now
we have somebody
can you imagine Winston Churchill I'm
just trying to go through like different
like great like you know
coming together speeches even the fake
speech from Independence Day was way
better than whatever that statement is
I'm gonna read it again this time we're
gonna try not to laugh because this is
serious this is like I'm picturing like
George W bush being like so uh well
we're building a coalition and uh we're
gonna be like like the Justice League
and tell Tony Blair America we're
calling dibs we're Batman you're gonna
have to be Superman
okay
I'm gonna read it okay
no wait this is serious stuff people are
dying and they want you to take it
seriously oh God we are Harry Potter
and William Wallace the navi and Han
Solo were escaping from Shawshank and
blowing up the Death Star we are
fighting with the Harkness
and challenging Thanos
yes can I ask sure aren't half the
people they just named dead
or want to be yes but I mean like
William Wallace dead Han Solo dead
[__] half the people that challenge
Thanos [__] dead yeah they're also
[__] make-believe like their [__]
War prospects
yeah and the only the only place I want
to see William Wallace was real the only
thing that I want that I want to be like
Shawshank redeem the only thing that I
want to be like Shawshank Redemption is
I want to see zelinski's name carved on
a load-bearing beam yes uh yeah yeah by
the way I want to point out something
right so they mixed in all this [__]
fictional gobbledygook and then they
added William Wallace because of a movie
so like this is even written by somebody
that just thinks that like the
historical figure of William Wallace is
just a movie I don't know remember that
Mel Gibson movie uh well who did Kevin
Costner play in Dances with Wolves I
don't think we want to reference that
movie right now super serious war is
super serious
that I as soon as I saw that I want
Russia to win now yeah by the way this I
have been
uh I have been Temple about this whole
thing sitting on the fence baby I don't
give a [__] about either side that tweet
right there is I want you to know it's
February 20th great job 2023 it's 4 39
p.m the turning point for marsh when he
started rooting for Russia was that
[__] tweet I'm rooting for them now
gotta get up
[Music]
yeah downstairs
okay sorry there you go
and so the ukrainians Escape Shawshank
the Honda poster of Putin on a bear I
hate this chair